pick it's a familiar story unfortunately
Robert Spencer author of the complete
infidels Guide to the Quran thank you
for joining us
um this is something is this the new
normal for Europe do you believe these
types of stories because it feels like
we're hearing about them almost on a
daily basis
there's no doubt that it's the new
normal for Europe the Islamic State Isis
has called for these kinds of attacks
they've made a concerted effort to get
people into Europe to launch these kinds
of attacks from within the refugee
influx remember that two of the Paris
attackers last November were refugees
this man was an Algerian National who'd
come into Europe in 2012 and so there
are many many others embedded among the
peaceful refugees who are actually
Islamic jihadis they're going to be many
many more attacks like this one and the
question is is how much at risk is the
United States we know that Europe has
struggled with this they have a large
number of Migrant refugees to your point
that have come in
um what about the United States where
are our vulnerabilities
the our vulnerabilities are everywhere
as the more people uh among the more
refugees that Barack Obama brings in the
more likely this kind of thing is to
happen in the United States remember
that tashfin Malik the San Bernardino
Shooter had passed five separate
background checks from five different
U.S agencies and so we're bringing in
only refugees who are vetted and checked
and that vetting is completely useless
what's interesting and to that point I
want to get back to Europe and France
one of the suspects
um arrested in the death of the priest
in in northern France had actually had
been on their radar very much so even
had a tracking bracelet on his ankle uh
and yet they were unable to stop this
attack but we don't have I don't think
anyone has the resources to follow the
suspects 24 hours a day
that's the Isis strategy and see that
man's tracking bracelet it was actually
turned off for three hours every morning
and that's when he did this attack and
the Isis strategy is to overwhelm law
enforcement in Europe and the United
States with so many of these jihadis
that we just can't possibly keep track
of all of them and it's working
is how do we stop this and I would
assume that you would believe this is
going to continue will it will it
increase in its frequency
it's going to increase there's just no
doubt about that that's 100 certainty
one of the things we have to do is
really reconsider whether we need to
bring these refugees in when the Saudis
for example are taking absolutely none
of them and attributing their refusal to
the fact that there are terrorists among
them we ought to be able to do the same
thing
very good points Robert Spencer thank
you so much for joining us uh this
morning appreciate your comments
all right I want to get back to Donald
Trump who in about 24 minutes from now
we'll be outlining his